thank you chairman
well uh just now we have our they have a
the previous panelists that has briefed
the history
of arms control i will i want to focus
on
what's going on today and
actually my understanding the arms
control regime
and being undermined by the
junior bush administration when
he admitted and nuclear cooperation
with the india and since then
this uh arms control regime did not
achieve
anything substantial actually during
clinton's period
and the arms control regime make a big
progress
and for instance at that time and china
and the clinton administration revised
the the mtcr
and china
and joined that program and all of the
other they linked
these missiles and the warhead together
and
make a one after another progress but
since
and junior bush came to power and the
whole international arms control regime
stop making progress
well what i i want to focus on i want
talking about
the uh since this column about the
multilateralism
and i want to talk uh talk a little bit
about the bilateralism and
multilateralism
year arms control and
nowadays some people argue they say that
look at that
in trump administering abundant
multilateralism
north korea's nuclear issues
and they make progress and so six-party
talks
advocated by china as a multilateralism
achieved nothing
big six-party tiles has one town for
years
and it went nowhere and finally it
stopped
and when trump abandoned the
multilateralism and talked with the
north korea directly just you know
yearly the americans rejected
to have a bilateral talk with the north
korea but now there is a
the trampoline says i only want to have
bilateral talk
so this issue becomes a china south
korea us
south korea north korea south korea and
then u.s
japan u.s china u.s and south korea
every
this is purely becomes a a
bilateral discussion this bilateral
discussion finally resulted
and really unexpected in the u.s
not square summit you can't believe it
and so there's a debate in china i don't
know how about the
uh whether it is uh the same
similar situation in the other countries
people say hey
and in the future the arms control
should be focused on multilateral
approach
or bilateral approach some people argue
that a bilateral approach is
more effective than multilateral someone
argued that
have bilateral first and then put them
together and
merge into a much lighter well there's a
lot of ideas
but from understanding this debate in
china at least
i think is a misleading people
understand that the core
of the issue not squares and nuclear
weapons
and actually no matter the
trump administration and adopt a
bilateral or multilateral
uh approach north korea already
decided to stop nuclear tests
the reason is that their the the goal of
their deterrence is
very low because the nuclear weapon is
the base
of north korea's regime security so they
just want to make the regime can survive
so how this linked to the nuclear
weapons means that
as long as u.s do not launch a war
against north korea
they can survive later her
live live along the domestic factors
so in that case so north korea already
prepared to have the last nuclear test
and then
want to say sit down to talk and to
release
all of these sanctions so when trump
administration said okay i won't talk to
you if you stop
actually north korea already prepared
for that because
it's just like what i said and so now we
we find that
whether a country means nuclear power
to abandon their nuclear weapons closely
relate to one thing
it's the regime security you see
north korea do not abandon the uh
nuclear weapons
because of when the uh apartheid regime
hand out
the uh the the power to the blacks
right so then there's no any securities
though and regime securities threat
to the black uh south africa
uh government and so they abandoned
after the uh the soviet union
and these independent states they think
they can get
security protection from the
international
community they can get this and some
countries think
they can join the nato to get security
protection nuclear umbrella from us
so they think there's no danger to their
security
especially this country went through the
democratization
right so when they adopt this western
democratic system
and then people never think that the
following threat will
uh threat threatened to their domestic
regimes
so they gave up the nuclear weapons
libya the same qaddafi never think
he will be toppled down if he gave up
the nuclear weapons
but after libya people's mentality
changed
they said hey wait a minute if you give
up nuclear weapons
if you're an enemy of the u.s you face
the danger of the war from the
launch by the u.s and then that war will
destroy you
now the country the destructive regime
so nowadays from under sunday
the arms control is no longer like
during the cold war only related to the
national security actually after the
gulf war
and i don't think any country faces the
danger being annexed by anyone
the international charter international
community has a prevent any
kind of annexation of the other states
but
no one can guarantee the regime
securities
so the why now affirmative now the arms
control
already faced a new situation from what
we
familiar with that during the cold war
okay so uh in my book
the inertia of the history and
china and the world in the rest of 10
years i think it will be
published in trent it's already
translated in english by oxford
and they came out uh the second half
this year
and in that book i focused in 2013
i predict that north korea is going to
stop nuclear tests but it
never give up nuclear weapons the reason
is that
the weapon is the base of the regime
security
if you get rid of nuclear weapons they
say hey the regime will be toppled
so my understanding now this is what
we must concern for the further arms
control and
if we want to these countries to give up
the nuclear weapons
we must talk about how to guarantee the
regime security
unfortunately like these countries
iran and the north korea the western
countries say hey
for the sake of political correctness we
cannot even we
privately we uh uh promise
we guarantee the security uh regime
security but we cannot see that
but for these countries they say hey we
need to see publicly
to the to the public and make everyone
knows that
you do not want to put down the regime
so this is
what we're facing second it's about
how about the the armed the regime of
the
uh arms uh uh non-proliferation my
understanding non-pollution regime is
being undermined like i said from the
junior bus period
and then i think it will be further
undermined by the
trump administration because this
administration have no interest
in arms control they don't think that
this region
the armed arms control regime community
has any meaning and that i don't mean
that they because they uh they have
a different mentality and they do not
fear about the
danger of war but trump really gave the
first
priority to economic interest
but for this government they don't think
that
any security interests should be
overwhelm
the economic interests since they gave
us
first priority to the economic interest
i don't think
they want to spend effort time and
energy on this
issue well all of us
agree arms control regime is a
multilateral
and you need the leadership especially
for nuclear weapons
and the u.s have to undertake the
leadership if
u.s do not undertake the leadership who
can replace that who can
function like a leader so my
understanding
neither china or russia is able to play
that role
so that means we are going to have no
leadership
for the further arms control community
and without the leadership how can we
make progress
i think this is just related to what we
discussed
yesterday and
during the cold war and we're so lucky
like uh professor uh crippen said
and soviet union and the us provide
a joint leadership even the confront
against
on everything but i don't know why
they work so closely they provide a
joint leadership
for the nonproliferation unfortunately
today
we don't have to america we don't have
g2
and who will how can we get a collective
leadership
for this the arms control regime
and from understanding that's very
difficult so
on this point i will see at this moment
if we want to have this regime resuming
its energy like the clinton's period
and we still can only wait for
something happen and to us
you have a new leadership they have
increasing arms control they think this
series
this is related to the security of the
whole world for the
seven million population on the earth
and
only they're really concerned they're
serious but
if they consider hey the money is more
serious than this issue
and i doubt the last thing i want to say
is that now the arms control for
manslaughter i totally agree
with the nuclei and
these arms control can no longer limit
it
within the nuclear regime
it should expand to other fields the
reason
is that because the nuclear weapons are
guaranteed
the basic security for the whole world
that means there's no danger of the
global war
meanwhile and the country's especially
major powers
becomes a brief to attack each other
on the website on the internet
so the federal war actually already
fought every day
now man situation in that how can we
prevent
this kind of a separate uh a cyber war
or
separate attack escalating into
something dangerous
i don't mean that it will exaggerate to
nuclear war
but then if we do not have the arms
control on this
this world becomes a big problem and
actually
like a clinton said this weber world
is a primitive uh uh
society there's no any sufficient
international law or regulation to
govern this
area so that's really what we need
the last point is that and
how can we make the major powers to
cooperate with each other
in arms control and first we need to
advocating of the looking for the common
interests shared
by them if the major powers
do not recognize there's a common or
shared interest you can hardly expect
them to cooperate with each other
no no reason no no no no ending to
driving them to
work together and so at this moment
from understanding and because the world
has a heavily relay on the digital
economy
and because the world heavily relay
on the the internet
internet already becomes like
electricity
it's a not only not like nuclear weapons
for the military for a national secret
but for the life
for everything so this
area and actually should we have a lot
of
shared interest in the uh
in this field and
in this uh how can we copy each other
my understanding you can never have
everyone is
equal that's a politically correct
with because this uh abraham is
the equal sovereignty adopted by the u.n
charter
so people say hey politically there's a
principle
that's true but when you come to a
corporation
you need the leadership that means some
country must have a more
equal than that should be more equal
than others
otherwise they won't provide leadership
leadership besides the
cost they have to pay for it and
so in that way my understanding in this
in this regime we at least need us
neither the equity only among the major
powers
make the major part feel we are few
countries are equal
and then talking about shared interests
they will work
with each other and finally i would say
at least
at this moment
how much we can advocating
multilateralism as a principle
to governing all major powers
foreign policy i don't know at least
and the white house never feel
uh awkward or that have any difficulty
to publicly say
we do not like the multilateralism
no even you have the hypocritical
garments
for the major powers at least they see
the
multilateralism is correct unilaterally
is wrong
now even hypocritically now people
feel they do not feel ashamed to say no
we don't like multilateralism
so how can we make a martial life from
it's a
political internationally political
crackness
this is very important at this moment
thank you
[Music]